now let's work out an example that shows
how to use the pairwise independent
sampling theorem to actually do some
sampling and estimation so let's
remember that our basic theorem says
that if we have n independent random
variables pairwise independent with the
same mean and variance and we look at
their average the probability that their
average difference from the mean by more
than a given tolerance Delta is less
than or equal to this formula here which
is the standard deviation over Delta
squared times 1 over n now we're just
going to be plugging into this formula
but I want to state it here for the
record to remember that this is the
pairwise independent sampling theorem
that we're given which is what we've
seen in general allows us to calculate
the degree of confidence we can have the
probability that we have given N or the
N that we need given how confident we
want to be so let's go ahead and do the
example and what I want to think about
is the possibility of swimming in the
Charles now that Charles has a coliform
count coliform err some rather
undesirable bacteria that are associated
with fecal matter and we want to know
whether it's safe to swim in the Charles
that's a petri dish showing a kind of
sample of bacteria that you might grow
culture to see what's going on the
Environmental Protection Agency requires
that the average CMD the coliform
microbial density on the dish is less
than 200 and what we want to do is
figure out whether when we do a sample
of CMDs around the river and we get some
numbers out whether in fact we will
conclude that the coliform that the
average CMD is less than 200 and we need
to convince the EPA of that now we're
never going to be certain but what we're
going to do is take 32 measurements at
random times the locations around the
river and we're going to collect these
32 measurements of CMD and it's going to
turn out that although of
you of them are over 200 the average is
well under 200 the average of the 32
samples that we've taken is 180 and our
task now is to convinced the
Environmental Protection Agency that on
the basis of our data on that the
average in the whole River is really
less than 200 even though we're a couple
of places it was over a hundred but on
average it was 180 can we convince the
EPA that the actual average is less than
200 and so we're trying to convince them
that our estimate based on the sample is
within 20 of the actual average we got
180 so if our estimate is when 20 of the
truth then in fact the average is less
than 200 well how are we going to do
that well let's look at the parameters
in the in the st. pairwise independent
sampling theorem and see what we have so
C is the actual average CMD in the river
that's what we don't know we're trying
to estimate it Oh
so our samples correspond to a random
variable we're taking a measurement of
the CMD in a random time in place and
that defines a random variable whose
expectation is the unknown C so we've
defined by our sampling process a random
variable with mean mu in fact we've done
it with 32 variables so n samples mean
and independently in the mutually
independent random variables wall with
mean equal to the number that I'm trying
to estimate and a n is the average of
the n CMD samples so we have an a 32
that we're trying to understand so
here's the independent sampling theorem
formula and let's see what I know
already I'm gonna plug in knowns what I
know is that n is 32 mu is the unknown
see that we're trying to estimate and
the Delta that it matters to us is 20
because we want to argue that if our
average of 180 our measurement of 180
was within 20 of the truth then in fact
we're under the 200 that the epa
specifies so let's plug in
our known parameters 32 for n and 20 for
the tolerance and they plug in here and
that leaves me with the standard
deviation which the formula requires and
I have to plug in and that is a problem
because we don't know what the standard
deviation is now sometimes you couldn't
kind of argue that you can figure out
what the standard deviation is because
you have a theory of what the random
distribution is of these measurements
and therefore you can calculate what its
standard deviation should be other times
you can actually take a sample of the
deviation of your sample and use that as
an estimate of the sample of the actual
standard deviation but that's kind of
circular and we're not going to go there
but another way to do it is to say that
if you had some bounds on the the
maximum possible discrepancy of your
measurements if you had done these kinds
of sampling testings of CMDs for a long
time and you had never observed two that
were more than 50 apart then what you
could argue is that the the range of
measurements is going to be only 15 so
what we can do is if we say that L is
the maximum possible difference that
we'll ever measure among samples then in
fact what you can say is that the the
worst possible standard deviation when
your random variable is ranging over an
interval L is L over 2 and you can check
that algebraically but for now let's
just take that as a fact if you know
that the that when your measurements are
going to differ by at most L between Max
and min the standard deviation can't be
more than L over 2 and if we know that L
is 50 then I got a number finally to
plug in because now I can plug in 25 for
Sigma so let's do that
and when I do that I come out with this
calculation that says that the
probability that my average minus C was
greater than 20 that my 1 a 32 which we
said was 180 was
more than 20 away from the truth is less
than 0.05 or flipping it around the
probability that my average is within 20
of the truth is greater than 0.095 and
so we would like to be able to say now
that the probability that the unknown
see is the 180 that we measured for a 32
plus or minus 20 is at least 95% that
seems to be what the theorem told us
let's go back to the theorem says that
the probability that a 32 which we
measured to be 180 minus C is less than
or equal to 20 is greater than 0.95 so
we should go back and tell the EPA that
the probability is that C is less than
200 with probability of 0.9 5 and we'd
be pretty tempted to say that but it's
not right it's technically the wrong
thing to say and why is that well it's
an important idea which is that we're
talking about something other than
probability here we're talking about
confidence not probability and let's
explain that a little bit more here's
the issue the number C is a number in
the real world it's an actual physical
quantity which is the average CMD in the
river we don't know what it is but that
does not make it a random variable it is
or it isn't within less than 200 or more
than 200 and so on what's going on is
that we have created a probabilistic
model of sampling that is designed to
have in our probabilistic model this
unknown constant there's nothing
probabilistic about the constant we've
introduced the probability by thinking
of our random sampling as random
variables we control the randomness we
can't say that C is random our
measurements are random so the right
thing we can say is that the possible
outcomes of our sampling process can
persuasively be modeled as a random
variable so what we can say is that the
probability that our sampling process
will yield an average that's within
twice
t of the true average is at least 0.95
so that's a funny thing to say what you
going what you do is you go to tell the
EPA that says look we don't know what
the real average is but we have a
process that gets the right answer 95%
of the time to within plus or minus 20
and we measured it and our process that
we booked is right 95% of the time came
in with an answer that said it's less
than 200 okay now that's the right thing
to say that's the truth we're making a
probabilistic statement about our the
general properties of our sampling
process and saying okay our sampling
process is usually right the sampling
process said less than 200 so we think
that that's probably right but we can't
say it is right and we can't even say
it's right with any probability it's
just the way that are mostly reliable
process yielded an answer and that's an
important idea distinction to
distinguish so it's our estimate that
that's correct with probability 0.95 now
this is a long thing to say to the EPA
and what we'd like to go back is
language that says that that we think
that the real average see is within 20
of 180 is probably within 20 of 180
because that's the what our test seemed
to say but we're not allowed to talk
about the probability that C has some
value or other so instead we summarized
the story about how we measured C using
a probabilistic process that's right 95%
of the time by saying that C is 180 plus
or minus 20 at the 95% confidence level
and that is the that's a shorthand way
of saying we've got this process that we
believe in that measured this unknown
quantity and told us what it was so the
morrow here that will wrap up this
little video with is that when you're
told that some fact holds at a high
confidence level because of some tester
or some random experiment or some polar
pollster
you have to remember that is that what
that implies is that somebody designed a
random experiment to try to get an
estimate of reality and you can always
question whether you believe in that
random experiment it's important to
understand that there is some random
experiment back there and you should be
wondering about what is it and do I
believe in it an even more important
question to ask is why are you hearing
about this particular experiment how
many other experiments were tried and
not reported the point is that people
can perform various kinds of tests and
at the ninety-five percent or higher
confidence level but when the tests
don't come up with an interesting result
they don't bother to publish them or
announce them and of course when they
come up with a surprising result which
is gonna be wrong one out of twenty
times those are the results that they
publish and submit and advertise because
they sound good in fact the major drug
company GlaxoSmithKline after paying
three billion dollars for as a judgment
against them in 2012 for suppressing the
results negative results of clinical
trials just agreed to now make public in
February 2013 all of the clinical trials
that they perform so that you're not
just learning about the cherry-picked
positive results but about the negative
ones as well and in fact
get this point home you might want to
look at the cartoon at xkcd which
explains how it is that there's a
problem with green jelly beans at the
95% confidence level